i tell people all the time that
government
can make laws
but they can't
change hearts
[Music]
hello my name is pastor corey brooks and
i'm coming to you from the south side of
chicago on top of a roof where i'm
living in this tent for 100 days you got
it 100 days on a block that the chicago
sun times in an article called the most
dangerous block in all of chicago o
block named after a young man named od
perry who was shot and killed and the o
was adopted in his name for o block
we decided to keep the o but turn it
into opportunity block so for 100 days
fox is allowing me to take you on the
journey with us
as we talk about the violence in chicago
the possible solutions but also talk
about how we're trying to build this
community center not how we're trying to
build it but how we're going to build
this community center on the south side
of chicago to help change the trajectory
of so many people's lives and tonight i
have with me a guest now here's what's
so tripped out about my guest
he came all the way from georgia y'all
all the way from georgia and he's here
on the south side of chicago and i
wanted to talk about that because
i just believe it's so important when
race
is being
such a factor in dividing us
so every time i get the opportunity
to prove to people that race is not the
biggest problem that we face in the city
of chicago i want to try to do that
whenever i have people who are
like-minded who come to the south side
of chicago to share with us and what
we're trying to do i want to introduce
them to you but most of all i want to
find out what is their reason why are
they here so real fast i want to ask my
friend
jim purcell who is from athens georgia
um man what brings you here
on the south side of chicago
you
uh
the relationship um just
finding out what you're doing uh through
my pastor and at athens church on c and
he he found you on twitter and
uh he had a heart for what you're doing
and then
i once i started watching and keeping up
and then i had the pleasure of meeting
you in athens and andes
or desi and just
i believed in what you're doing and
i've been involved with a ministry in
athens that
[Music]
tries to take race out of everything
we're doing and it is
a ministry that has a school that all
started with football and
but just a heart for the people that are
having to live in
conditions that just don't really seem
right that no one should have to do that
and especially the children that's
that's what really is is heartbreaking
to watch so
excuse me just seeing what you're doing
is just amazing and i wanted to have
some small part in it and just get to
know everything better yeah thank you
one of the things you said that i want
to ask you about is that you said that
it started as a result of football
what was the context of that i know you
all started school k through five
and it was started
not
out of a school it was started first
from football can you explain that
because i think people need to hear the
context the background and how that came
about especially since we're talking a
little bit about race right well i want
to give credit where credit's due and
there's a local pastor there hal
farnsworth at redeemer presbyterian
i think wrestled with the thought
of knowing about the poverty and and all
the problems
in clark county where athens is located
and primarily uh
in the black community of just people
just struggling through poverty so bad
he wanted to do something and
so
his question was how can i bring the
black
community together with white community
some common bond and he decided football
was it and he started a program
uh for football called
the downtown falcons and
that started off with a few kids and
just kept growing and and now that part
of it's up over
i think 300
children that actually play football
and then from there
the ministry decided we need
to give these children excuse me another
children
a school opportunity and just
uh
something that they could get some
stability in their lives and
and some direction and love and and so
many things so
football became school and and now we've
taken it even further to include
a program called our daily bread that
where we're feeding people every day and
so
that football started
starting everything there you know
that's really important because
we're living in a day in time especially
in chicago where
people want to think that a lot of our
problems are a result of racial issues
and i beg to differ
and i think all the problems that we're
faced with
if we all work together and i say this a
lot about being neighborly if we can
just be neighborly there's absolutely
nothing
on that we can't overcome whether it's
giving food to people who need it
creating education
i know for you you've been a mentor and
that's we're really big on that there
are so many young people
in chicago
who need positive mentors and
need life change and i've been able to
witness for myself
how positive and strong it is when you
have a mentor regardless of
their color and i wish we had time we
would talk about how you're a mentor to
a kid of another race and
how important that is you know but just
tonight that you're here on the south
side of chicago
and
we're talking about the issues and
we're praying about the solutions uh
speaks volumes and i hope that america
can be just like we are tonight yeah one
yeah well and i think we all want
somebody to believe in us and we want to
know that somebody cares and that's what
i saw with these children
when football became a basketball
program some of the
kids i had the most trouble with on my
team just really want some attention
they wanted to know that i loved them
and i cared about them and
and that goes all the way from childhood
to adulthood and
so i think you're right we you asked me
a while ago uh
what my word
of this meeting was and and i said grace
but
i think we all need grace towards each
other
we're all a challenge we're all a mess
in our own way and
and it's tough to love each other
sometimes but
that's what we're supposed to do i mean
it's it's very plain you can easily read
that
you know i tell people all the time that
government
can make laws
but they can't
change hearts
and
it's god and people
yeah that work on the hearts
and so i want to thank you for what
you're doing in athens georgia thank you
for coming all the way to chicago i'll
be back i hope our fox family uh follows
you and uh please remember
projecthood.org where we're building
this center on the south side of chicago
to help as many people as we can to stop
as much violence as we possibly can
we need your help and your assistance
and uh we're gonna keep coming to you
every day talking about these fireside
chats these rooftop revelations so i'll
see you tomorrow night
god bless you and god thank you
god bless amir
you